Parliament will consider how the II use
long-term budget should develop MEP czar
calling for new revenue streams to help
fund EU programs they also want the
kovat 19 economic recovery package to be
as ambitious as possible EU programs
must continue to run in 2021 in the
event there's no agreement on the next
seven year budget by the end of the year
MEP s will vote on a request to the
Commission to set up a contingency plan
for the --use 2021 budget developing
kovat 19 tracing apps to fight the
pandemic must comply with EU data
protection laws Parliament will debate
the use of contact tracing apps designed
to map monitor and mitigate the spread
of coronavirus Parliament will vote on
new EU Tire labeling rules designed to
better inform consumers about fuel
efficiency noise level and grip which
should help lead to a drop in emissions
from Road Transport MEP s are expected
to adopt EU wide water reduce standards
the goal is to promote the use of
treated wastewater in agricultural
irrigation and help alleviate water
scarcity
you